josh hawley is of course the senator
from missouri he joins us tonight with
these documents senator thanks so much
for coming in and for doing this so this
was aimed tell me if i'm just
characterizing this at our population
yeah that's exactly right as it turns
out tucker the people that the bite
administration thinks are the real
threat to america it's not the drug
cartels it's not foreign threats it's
you it's the american people if you have
questions about covid if you have
questions about covet masks you have
questions about the covet vaccine this
administration wanted you to be
monitored this disinformation board was
set up to go after you that's what the
documents say by the way election
integrity same story the documents
specifically mention that they needed to
be a disinformation board because some
people were having questions about
election integrity some people had
questions about january 6th well we
couldn't have that and this board was
set up to monitor that that was what was
in their sites and i tell you tucker it
just gives the lie to what they were
saying in public
so the federal government partnering
with private companies to censor
americans who criticize pfizer
is unconstitutional isn't it
yeah you would sure think so i mean this
idea that the government is going to
stand up an institution that's going to
monitor american speech that's going to
treat americans political speech tucker
core political speech about political
issues as something that needs to be
monitored that needs to be countered
this was going to be a state propaganda
machine this board was supposed to push
out counter information to americans who
are raising questions and yes to partner
with big tech the whole idea here in the
documents show this is that the
government would get together with big
tech and collect information
on americans who were raising these
questions i mean how dare you that's the
whole idea here is that the government
of big tech these companies would
partner together in this massive
censorship campaign it is truly truly
chilling
it's it's beyond belief and thank you
for proving what everyone suspected um
beyond a shot of a doubt senator josh
hawley of missouri thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight